tu veux celui je vais t'expliquer je
vais t'expliquer la différence qu'il ya
entre lutter contre des gens et lutter
contre un phénomène dont l'idéologie
islamiste encore une fois j'ai bossé non
mais vous devriez le faire mais moi je
m'attaque pas aux gens et je vais même
te dire que j'ai tout mon avis ça toute
ma vie j'ai suivi ses disques qu'est-ce
qu'elles ont institué j'étais à 100% ça
travaille pas ah bah oui même en tête
que ce rail pas mais moi j'ai des textes
qui sont préparés et vous nous avez un
espèce de torchon et je sais que tu
dessous et donc à lui ça va bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous plaît là l'a tous eu tous ceux qui
nous regardent on se crée en salle des
professeurs jean
marie quelque chose quand je suis avocat
c'était commis d'office pour défendre
des gens et j'ai défendu des clandestins
il y avait des gens se retrouvent à voir
ce que tu vois si si c'est des gens
comme toi qui disais mais comment vous
êtes contre eux étaient des gens lire et
vous êtes contre l'immigration
clandestine et vous défendez des
clandestins eh bien oui parce que je
pense que même s'il était clandestins
ils avaient le droit d'être défendu par
un avocat mais assez soir à bonal oscars
et donc je les fais et il y avait des
gens pour me le reprocher gens des gens
qui comme toi ne savent pas faire la
différence c'était et ce sens qu'ils
avaient enfreint les lois marine mais
pas c'est pas là les choses la c1 c'est
un c'est un symbole politique pour
l'instant il n'est pas vous voulez si ce
n'est que j'ai le courage aux gens si ça
si tu n'as salle mais c'est une rage
rage d'affronter une personne tu auras
pas le courage d'affronter la masse je
me tiens voilà je me suis ajusté soit le
courage d'affronter une gamine de 15 ans
tu n'as pas le courage de le faire c'est
ça que tu n'as pas eu le courage de
refuser donc demain tu n'auras pas le
compter toutes les vaut tous les voiles
et toutes les manifestations de l'islam
radical et surtout si tu prétends que
l'islam est compatible avec la
république faut que tu sois cohérent
honnêtement je trouve c'est quoi je vais
je trouve que c'est très intéressant ce
débat parce que ça révèle quand même une
partie du projet d'eric zemmour une
partie de sa brutalité du tout une
partie sa dureté qui est juste inutile
l'utilité c'est encore une fois faire
des lois et les verra appliquer
s'attaquait des personnes s'attaquent à
des gamines marine le pen les humilier
en riant disait marine le pen on
jurerait pas de photo avec toi parce que
parce que je suis contre le risque
devrait juste vous êtes contre le voile
cette jeune fille ray kay l'air très
sympathique a voulu faire à un self avec
vous imaginons demain vous êtes
président de la république n 2 pas
enlever le voile vous avez fait vous
avez vous vous étiez bien avec elle et
vous avez david et vous l'avez dit voilà
c'est vrai vous avez eu envie d une âme
à la douane oui mais ça veut dire que
voulez vous la renvoyez mais l eau non
alors mais cette jeune fille elle et
françois oui c'est ça brille donc vous
faites quoi et bien alors à une amende
voilà maintenant les choses tous les
jours avoir une amende et oui elle ne
respecte les voyageurs qu'elle vous
dérange pas elle ne respecte mais si ça
vous dérange est le problème je vais
vous dire monsieur hanouna c'est qu'en
réalité il ya 20 ans y avait pas de
problème de voile jamais personne n'en
portait pourtant il y avait déjà des
musulmans 1 il y avait déjà des gens qui
étaient venus dans notre pays personne
aucune femme ne portait le voile mais
les forces et que des islamistes ils ont
réussi à convaincre ou à faire pression
dans des quartiers et beaucoup de
français d'ailleurs musulmans vivent
sous cette pression là la pression leurs
proches
là le fait de dire mais ta femme si elle
n'est pas voilée c'est que en réalité
elle n'est pas pudique d'affilée que c
est toutes ces pressions qui s'est
développée elle s'est développée parce
qu'encore une fois on n'a pas posé la
ligne la ligne c'est ça c'est un
uniforme islamistes et accessoirement
c'est un acte de soumission des femmes
moi je suis encore une fois
fondamentalement opposés mais je me pose
encore une fois par la loi mais les
cachets
contre vannes et quand je ne pourrai pas
le faire vous rendez compte de la dola
de la vie de cette jeune fille si besoin
vous êtes présidente et qu'elle est elle
desservait ne savait rien les jours elle
va prendre mais vous n'en savez rien
peut-être sera-t-elle libéré vous ne
savez pas ce qu'il ya derrière ce voile
et opposant sa mère j'ai reçu pour ce
soit sur le gâteau qui était très
heureuse de porter le voile c'était leur
choix certainement oui et bien
certainement mais y en a beaucoup
d'autres pour lequel c'est pas le choix
et moi ce que je dis c'est que beaucoup
ont utilisé ce voile en réalité pour
démontrer qu'ils étaient en quelque
sorte visuellement propriétaire de ce
territoire
m